we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
[Music]
hey hey folks here we are happy saint
patty's day
top of the morning to you luck of the
irish i love it kiss me
this is my wish this is are we just
doing costumes now a bunch how many
where does it end matt mother's day what
are we doing i'll dress as a mom i don't
care i can be octomom
we'll have eight kids how you been man
good good minute i'm excited for a drink
i love st patties it's the last racist
holiday you can go all in i guess the
gay pride parade is pretty offensive
not to them not to them
but it's every stereo i like the
stereotypes all in one place all in one
day i'll tell you that that uh gay pride
parade you ain't getting to the comedy
cellar that night no
they're blocking that whole way it's a
huge [ __ ] block and you cannot get past
that parade but i went i go every year i
live like a block away and it's a
[ __ ] ball
balls
but yeah good times it's a lot but saint
patty's fit simmons has a great uh fun
fact he said if you look at st paddy's
day
nine months later all these kids are
born
because everybody [ __ ] all these uh mix
and o'reilly's and whatnot they all bang
on
john stewart had a great bit back in the
day about uh st patrick's day uh the
parade he would say you know they won't
let the gays march in the parade and he
goes yeah because you don't want
anything to mess with the dignity of
that parade
because when you when you're peeing
behind a dumpster you don't want some
gay guy checking you out
that's a great bet great bit
well in uh in honor of the uh the uh
emerald isle the blarney stone
we got our old pal jamie here doing some
cocktails well what do you got for us
today jake that looks that looks
horrible i'm gonna put it out there that
doesn't look good it was requested to do
boozy shamrock shape yeah who who
requested this i think peters
he just wants the cookies that's why he
did this [ __ ] i was concerned but you
know like i came on here last time doing
the coquitos so like i'm just the the
person who does the sweets oh not the
whipped cream i just came from a pizza
judging contest i'm gonna be [ __ ] my
pants
this you live like people think
americans live they go eat pizza all day
in a contest and then they drink shakes
for dinner do your best guys you know
this is this is a lot for you you deal
with a lot of dairy well yeah but you
know what that's the thing like i made
it so you know it's not the mickey d's
kind so i was able to get like oat milk
involved
ice cream you know what i'll say this my
order for coffee i go usually a little
oat milk on the side
whole milk is my second favorite i think
oat milk tastes the best it's the best
you got me on oat milk i love it it's
good we got a little carried away with
almond almond kind of sucks almond's not
great that's not good it's a healthy
option but it's not the best tasting is
it even healthy i don't know who knows
milk is the ultimate tea so we're like
for years people like are you drinking
all your milk right strong bones philip
does the body good
what the hell happened that was all
disproven by the way it's like full of
fat and [ __ ] and cholesterol and all
this stuff so yeah and it doesn't help
you i was watching a madman where uh
roger sterling has a heart attack and
he's like a giant of milk cause they're
like it's good for you kids oh look at
that oh geez the pants look at this oh
my god
a lot of green
this looks delightful the cherry and you
put like little sprinkles on there too
oh yeah this is the vibe this is the
shamrock shake with the vanilla vodka
that's what's in there oh and a tiny bit
of creme de menthe because that's what
it calls for but i didn't overdo it
because i know you guys don't really i
don't have the mint that much
i don't like mint is soaked milk
chocolate chip get the [ __ ] out of it
too much and it's strong to do creme de
menthe like a little bit goes a long way
that packs a punch that's all that's
that's a lot that's good though this is
a weird one for saint patty's i feel
like i thought we would just do like
irish whiskey because
you would never drink this [ __ ] you get
your [ __ ] kicked daddy if you ordered
this you're not wearing that either
that's a special day
but yeah no you're right nobody would
order this but no wait what's in this
again sorry it's good so we have the
vanilla ice cream and i found the the
300 calorie max vanilla ice cream oh
yeah
i did vanilla oat milk uh we're going to
lose vodka
a little bit of that creme de menthe and
green food coloring
it's the healthiest thing in here
yeah exactly i've said it before i'll
say it again i wish you were my mom
[Laughter]
yeah apparently these have been around
since like 1970. oh okay did it start as
an alcoholic drink or is it it was you
know the mickey d's drink it started
there oh is that right yeah so it's just
mickey d mcdonald's irish never put that
together yeah ronald mcdonald red hair
there you go ginger it was just a green
vanilla shake really
they just you know needed to be festive
for the holiday yeah so it was just a
seasonal treat like the mcrib yeah
exactly
there's a little bit of that in there
too
all right you know in chicago they die
that river that runs through chicago or
whatever they dye that green they have
their own saint patrick's day that's how
big of alcoholics they are in chicago
yes and what's that awful [ __ ] they
drank that shot oh what's it called i
know
man i'm sure you could find it no it's
like it's you god awful but i take a
shot every time in chicago yeah it
tastes like uh
myrtle up my lord my lord that's it it's
so bad it's like cough drops you you
make a face after it like you just found
out you were adopted it's that that's
the tape it's just it's like terrible
yeah it's rough it says horrible
multiple times i'll forget i've had it
so i'll be in chicago though you gotta
drive my lord someone will send it to me
on stage and i'm like ugh yeah i take it
i'm just like kill me right and the
reaction gets a laugh and then of course
years later you do it again you're like
oh i've done this
yeah exactly
oh yeah look at that there it is the
chicago green
i love it a lot of shamrock shake yeah
yeah
that's why the people they look like
they do uh no the chica the chicago
people man are some of the i would say
like great crowds top five comedy
audience in the country easily easily
and what a great city oh one of the best
segregated quite a bit yeah but a great
time there's some issues there for sure
you're hearing a white guy say that i
already hate myself a little bit
chicago's lovely yeah go to the south
side
um yeah great time yeah put it down i
know it's going to be a problem yeah
this is what killed patrice
well he was a o'neill
i actually saw him at the irish show i
saw him there too at comics yeah that
was what like
11 years ago maybe more maybe more sean
donnelly hosted that's right that was a
great show
yeah patrice r.i.p one of the best in
the biz
[Laughter]
um you do the thing that roasters do you
know like remember like whenever you
roast someone you're like anyway this
guy looks like a [ __ ] pig but uh but
he's like honestly you're one of the
best guys i know i love you i love i
love the i love the sincere part of the
roast the downshift also i hope your
kids get aged
but anyway
salt of the earth
yeah geraldo used to do it and it was
really haphazard like you suck you're a
hack i never liked you why are you
famous but yeah you're doing a great
work
[Laughter]
yeah but that is damn good yeah you made
a hell of a [ __ ] i couldn't make that in
20 years you gave me an hour and a half
i couldn't make that i did it right
before i came down did you want a side
of whis uh whiskey with that i mean i
might need it i i can't believe it
that's a lot usually you get like a uh
like a coke back or something like that
to cut the taste i might need whiskey
just to cut this cut the sweets cut the
sweet kind you like this one right here
i'll [ __ ] with some elijah craig mark
you to do a little a little elijah we
got a seat for elijah how are you is
that a jewish thing it is what is that
passover good job
mark well done who is elijah
all right he was in the good the bad and
the ugly ah okay
anyway
um there's a guy who you hope shows up
i'll call i call him dead
anyway
but anyway uh
vodka cuts this pretty good i was in
sacramento all weekend oh great club
shout out to omar amber
great with molly great room great room
great staff
yeah yeah it's uh it's a [ __ ] of a
flight but i connected and i get this i
connect in seattle um i get uh why oh
gracias gracias because there weren't
many options so you go up and then over
yeah but i got upgraded delta one on
that shot
so i'm late guess who's sitting next to
me
chris o'connor
the comments the comics yeah the the
shane gillis friend
wait who am i thinking of yes that's him
man
sorry sorry we're going to the shane
gillis right they live together
the same building same building sorry
i've done his podcast yeah yeah yeah
great guy funny guy yeah yeah we oh dude
we had a great time coming back it's
like what a surprise you're next to a
comic and then
we're chatting for the first part then i
was like we should do a movie and we'll
both talk he knows a ton about movies so
we're talking movies oh wow and then i
was like i want to see something i
haven't seen he goes me too so we're
like scrolling through we've seen a lot
of this stuff on delta he goes oh the
last duel was good i was like all right
[ __ ] it i'll do the last duel and then
he's going i'm like you ever see sexy
bees
he goes no so he's watching his i'm
watching mine that we have like a little
talk it was like perfect little flight
that's like a sleepover almost it was
like a sleepover but he was in one
he was like
wow good for you chris you gotta up your
game mark i guess so you gotta up your
only flying with delta oh i know you got
the reserve card stick with it i got it
i got it yeah you're right you're right
i bought my last with delta flight with
the reserve card so i'm getting the
points and everything good
but yeah wow what do you think the last
duel is good it was good it's heavy it's
like rashomon right you know it's you
know what's cool about that movie
and spoilers here
i mean first off you so you've seen it
from other people's perspective yeah uh
and it's like so you have to see a
[ __ ] rape twice yeah so you're like
this is brutal and it's also like this i
can watch this on a flight i know that's
pretty cool the woman was incredible
oh yeah she stole the show her name
again jody comers is that what it was
what was her name last duel matt
she's amazing it's kind of a feminist
movie oh for sure yeah
and it still got it joey cody coma and
it's still it's relevant today
yeah dude and there's some badass action
in it that last scene was you're like
that's [ __ ] gladiator ridley scott i
know pulling out some stops yeah
and uh mark uh matt damon's got the theo
vaughn hair for some reason
pull up a picture tell me that he
doesn't look a little bit like matt
damon the last duel he it well it's like
kind of looks like theo right yeah yeah
yeah easy it is a good movie wow he does
holy [ __ ] yeah oh man
i think that guy's in rascal flatts
but yeah great but sexy beast is a hell
of a movie very stylized killer killer
acting uh tents i love that one i loved
so tense yeah man that movie uh there's
a lot of crazy stuff in in the last duel
and it's i mean
some of that [ __ ]
i mean
so it built well yeah it was a good
flick very people [ __ ] on matt damon and
ben affleck but they're [ __ ] awesome
man no no they make good [ __ ] they do
they do they know what they're doing i
mean ben affleck made that trash uh
movie where's the bartender i got like
clooney recommended it i got eight
minutes
it's brutal bummer it's a bummer yeah by
the way our pal
is hosting the oscars schumer schumer
i've been writing jokes for all weekend
really yeah that's [ __ ] who knows
like it went on but i'm throwing them at
her that's exciting yeah amy wanda and
virgina uh
king
who is it
that sounds right
maybe regina hall
king
hull
yeah king
no oh i had it damn should have stuck
with my guns
yeah that'll be fun but i got 18 jokes
about being a karen i got uh all kinds
of fun stuff
every joke i'm sure is too harsh for the
oscars
but me and sally cues we were watching
some old oscars just to like get some
some uh reference
wild jokes like which ones did you watch
we watched uh someone like 92 billy
crystal hosted crazy jokes i'm trying to
think of some but damn it's like holy
[ __ ] i can't believe they said that then
yeah well it's a different time
different time no one watches anymore
too it's kind of like
people are over that [ __ ] i know because
you know the problem is is it it got too
preachy it did and it's like we always
knew actors took themselves seriously
but like no one's watching for an
actor's opinion no that's the title
it's hilarious that marlon brando
trolled the oscars by having a native
american woman read like that's
hilarious but
when it becomes every actor being like
thank you i got this award but like
listen there's a lot of people hurting
out there yeah but just [ __ ] you you
read lives
i know i know exactly it's brutal it all
turned into a big activist thing
except when uh polanski won that was
shocking one that one polanski won 20
2003 or something yeah they all booed
him
i mean i mean why not you nominated him
i know exactly yeah i don't get it i
mean uh but yeah you're right it became
like a pat yourself on the back festival
instead of movies
yeah you know it should be about the
great movie what's the best movie of the
year and now it's like hey
are you being nice there should be a
separate category best woke movie of the
year
and then there should be just like best
movies genius and great call and then
there should be best comedy
and there should be a comedic actor you
guys don't respect i've said it before
eddie murphy for [ __ ] nutty professor
like that's harder than what a lot of
dramatic actors i agree i agree yeah
there's a reason why a lot of comedic
actors go serious but no serious actor
really goes comedy do they
like yeah ryan gosling's great in
comedies ah but he's not i'm he can't do
a dumb and dumber can he
jeff daniels ah good point a serious
actor yeah all right good point it can
be done it could be i guess uh de niro
did it too [ __ ] hilarious meet the
parents midnight run yeah all right but
he's kind of doing him in midnight right
i mean like mark wahlberg in a comedy is
still mark wahlberg right
true
yeah well mark wahlberg is so silly ted
is great remember we watch it in
vancouver love ted love ted too
i didn't even see the second one oh the
first one all right tattoos darker even
they they go harder
man these kind of actually work nice
together yeah it's not battle pairing
yeah this is the best parent since uh
chris tucker and jackie chan
you're right
all right yeah you're having some
whiskey too
oh you're mixing it up well i just had a
little yeah i had a little bit of both i
like these hats yeah the hats work like
laurel and hardy here this is great
anyway that people wore these in public
at some time in history
yeah speaking of delta one so i had an
awkward moment me and the lady went down
to the virgin islands
great time
the only problem is they uh i was
telling telling jamie they rolled their
sidewalks up at like nine so we'd be
hammered at 8 30 like the whole city's
shutting down damn so he's got to go
back to your hotel room and sloppily go
down on each other
it wasn't pretty
um
but
great time beautiful views it's a direct
flight from newark it's p you're in
paradise in three hours well can you get
more opposite than you were yeah exactly
exactly
and right when you get off the plane
they're like island time you know they
got the ladies and the full yellow
dresses shaking the maracas you're like
oh [ __ ] i made it and i flew there from
omaha by the way brutal but my point is
on a flight back
i got upgraded and she didn't and what
do you do
well i took the upgrade
what am i gonna do you guys have been
together long enough that that's not a
thing but if you this was a new couple
you would you would have to be like no i
want to be with you that's a good point
that's a good point here's my here's my
uh what's the word yeah when you you
make
compromise here's my compromise not a
good sign that it took him that long to
figure that one out here's my compromise
so i was in four the fourth row it's the
last row and then it hits to delta
comfort or whatever she's in comfort
right behind me there's a curtain you
know gotta keep the uh the plebeians out
the scum
the peasants
and i would eat half the food and go
i hand it back so i was helping the poor
you see i was charity
so that kind of helped it that helps
yeah i'd break off half the cookie and
give her half that's something that's
something
yeah i thought i said you want to come
up sit up here for a minute and i'll
give you some wings
wow yeah was the trip good great trip
great beautiful place the beaches it's a
little more lawless there you know we're
so we got regulations up the ass in new
york you know you can drink outside
there's people playing music it's the
beaches are insane it's great
sounds great man you know the food we've
got a catamaran we went out into the
ocean
that's [ __ ]
a lot of booze in during the day too
you said you sent some beach picks it
looked nice yeah yeah i was hammered at
all those picks um but you know you're
just sitting there on the beach getting
drunk and so like people kept texting me
like why are you responding so quick
you're on vacation i was like well i'm
just sitting here on the beach yeah i
know i think i was one of those people i
was like dude enjoy yourself i know you
respond on my text like that or you know
you're uh
i would like tag you on something on
instagram you'd like it immediately i'd
be like mark come on
i forgot a book too that was a bit
that's a big one a book on the beach is
pretty nice huge hard to beat that hard
to beat a book because the sun is hard
with the phone you can't get the glare
off and everything
but the books are so heavy
i get a kindle kindles are worth it you
have one yeah i got paper white paper
white yeah that's what they're called
yeah yeah it's good you got a kindle i
don't know maybe i'm gonna kill you it's
worth it no i have a refurbished one
it's just i forgot i got a good wreck
actually okay uh the the book mind
hunter
by john douglas who was an fbi profiler
there was a show mine hunter i saw it it
was a good show great show so you you
know a lot of it then yeah but it's it's
pretty cool some of the [ __ ] in the book
is like crazy dude
i mean he was one of the first like
legit profilers yeah and uh i mean
there's there was one story about uh he
just knew a guy had a lisp
oh yeah he was like i know this guy's a
lisp and they're like how do you know
he's like i know he's insecure about
something and i think it's a lisp and he
was right he's like i can't be certain
but i have a feeling he just trusted his
gut there's another one where a woman uh
went to the bathroom and her son got she
was in the bathroom for a long time in a
public restroom and the son got
kidnapped and they were questioning her
and he was like
he was like i got a feeling that
she said she didn't
you know that that he's not kidnapped i
have a bad feeling and at first she said
my son was kidnapped and he's like they
never say that
they always say my son's missing they
don't want to admit to themselves the
son was actually kidnapped then there
was another thing where he's like why
would she use a public restroom for that
long
knowing she had a son out there it's
insane
then another thing like his midden came
in the mail he's like that's not what
people usually do when they abduct it
was like too many things right uh he
caught her yeah and then she she killed
the kid whoa because she had a new guy
who was like i don't i want to you know
i love that i want to go to the
discotheque i don't know something like
that yeah he didn't want to he don't
want a [ __ ] kid it's crazy there's a
lot of crazy stories in it it's pretty
cool rachel feinstein was like you got
to read any john douglas book he's the
[ __ ] man she got me on the show
actually that was who wrecked it to me
mine hunter was the best uh netflix show
just killed it did they i mean i it
didn't come back
i don't know what happened but and they
brought that that sexy uh
ceo lady in at the end yeah he was
pretty i know and that guy whole
whatever his name was that that big guy
the beefy yeah that guy was awesome he
was great he's in nightmare alley
oh yeah yeah yeah but he's yeah that guy
is awesome nightmare alley that's where
you got to go to get an abortion in
texas
that's one of my oscar jokes for schumer
yeah exactly i don't think that one's
going to make it uh
although it could be like one of those
yeah and a bunch of women saying it
might be a little different that's true
i went for it it was cool yeah man mix
it up get something up you gotta do it
in their voice they had tina and amy
polo one year right wasn't that the
oscars or was that the goal i think both
gervase did such a good job with it it's
hard to top your face hard to topped
your face and they should have hired him
just to get the buzz
if they would have hired chappelle or
gervais
everybody would be so angry they would
watch because the numbers are through
the floor it could be a fun it's kind of
like how like hate watch it yeah like mr
potato head's like we'll say we're you
know we're we're genderless eminem crazy
yeah the oscars brought to you by mr
potato head and eminem those
that would be you they could host
let mr potato had hosted caitlyn jenner
presents dave chappelle hosting the
oscars
that's the show yeah
there's an x oscar presented by trump
what the [ __ ]
dude i watched uh power the dog is
[ __ ] awesome killer
that's a great movie great western you
know my theory about westerns
what well i just think they're so
popular what is it yellowstone old henry
power the dog there's another one that
just came out that's blowing up
we're so tuned into these phones that
you you watch western it's on the open
range it's it's no electricity it's
horses it's enemies it's territory
primal something badass about riding a
horse oh you ever done it
no you've never got on a horse
no
i'll go [ __ ] christopher reeve on
that thing are you kidding me
i'm not lasting
i was i was riffing i had a riff about
how uh you know
how putin you know rides a horse
shirtless and like how it's like a
badass thing i'm like i was like my one
of my wrists was like can you even
picture biden in a shirt on a horse
right now
it wouldn't be powerful he'd be like
dude get him off he's right he's gonna
get hurt that's true i can't picture
bite on a tricycle you know
but
maybe we'll get you on a we'll get you
on a pony we'll start you low with a
pony in central park i'll hold the reins
yeah and then we'll get up to a real
horse but
it's scary i always used to say like
drinking and driving is crazy but
imagine drinking and driving a horse how
horrible would that be and all these
cowboys were shit-faced yeah well well
the car is never just going to turn
against you exactly the horse is a
personality
um but yeah you gotta break a horse
right
that's like a whole thing you gotta
break its spirit right yeah a little bit
that's kind of a bummer it's kind of
[ __ ] up although as far as animals go
it's one of the better
treated animals true better to be a
broken spirited horse than just a
[ __ ] dead cow dead cow yeah
if i was a cow i just start walking to
india
to the sacred land
but you're right well they got a sugar
cube every now and then
every now and then they [ __ ] a farmer
i've seen the documentary or they get
[ __ ] or they get [ __ ] but i feel
like a human dick is so small that it
doesn't hurt yeah you're [ __ ] the
horse and the horse is like this is
doing nothing
are you in yet
we've all heard that one like oh you
[ __ ] size queen [ __ ] you
seabiscuit saw that on like an old jerry
springer thing like a documentary on
hulu it showed like i married a horse
yeah i brought a horse on jerry springer
and like kissed it and talked about
[ __ ] it
it's just a normal day
that guy was a that guy was a working
actor at his head shots he's like this
will propel me i'll be the horse guy
yeah uh what was i gonna oh yeah i rode
a horse when i was i was in cub scouts
and boy scouts so i had to ride horses
but my first time getting on a horse i
hopped up the horses are so tall that
when you're a kid you hop up and i had
too much momentum and i rolled right off
the other side cracked my neck it was
brutal they're so tall you forget yeah
and then you don't know how to gallop it
and you're supposed to use your legs to
hold your hold your body up and i didn't
know that so i was just sitting on it
and it's just
my balls are smashing on the saddle up
and down up and down and i eventually
just fell off damn it's wild
damn [ __ ]
i wish i have you ever seen
no never dressage
what mitt romney would do with the
horses it's like horse ballet oh really
i think i have seen this yeah yeah and
they kind of dip down and then back up
it's for those of you who think riding a
horse is too manly right right give this
a give this a whirl those equestrian
ladies are pretty hot though with the
with the brown pants
oh yeah really instead of a car yeah
what
that's a terrible because that's how
they advertise cars they're like this
has horsepower exactly
but a lot of horsepower
yeah yeah what do we got oh we got an ad
here you got to hate the youtube ads
there we go skip bed
is this the dressage how do you know
about this because it was like a big
thing that mitt romney did oh
binders of women
oh look at that little side step
there you go sister
that'd be great if this turned into like
you got served and the horses were like
you know
yeah i need a moonwalk or something
so what it is a pretty horse i mean
these are beautiful animals it's uh
majestic and i like that it looks like
it's been in there for a while it's got
like the shin guards yeah it looks like
patrick ewing
i think they sleep standing up because
their muscles are so strong that they
don't even feel it just standing there
yeah that's what i've heard
you ever seen a horse on its
side
i don't know yeah i have no idea are you
happy okay yeah wrong
standing up oh but they do sleep lying
down oh [ __ ] everybody they have the
ability to sleep standing up and okay
well one time my brother was in the
peace corps in africa oh there you go so
we went to visit him oh this is kind of
sexy look at these but these little sexy
positions if you had to bang a horse
which one which one are we looking at
here mark are you going why do you going
to load caramel brown i like that
caramel
remember it tells joke a horse is the
best animal to have sex with because you
know you always have a ride home
that's one of the classics that's a
great one
so yeah we went to africa and we were
walking me and my dad are walking down
the beach and these african kids roll up
with horses and they go
whatever and they're like you know how
much give us some money we'll let you
ride the horse and i was like oh no i
was like 19. i was like i don't know my
dad's like let's do it let's do it
no saddle nothing and my dad rode down
the beach like a badass because he grew
up on a farm kind of wow and then i
jumped on one and it bucked me off in
like 10 seconds and all the kids laughed
at me that's the scary one though that
was scary the wild wild african horses
holy [ __ ] do you have any footage of
that man pull up some footage of like
horse rodeo
i mean that looks [ __ ] brutal
yeah those
black kids were laughing at me reminding
me back i was like i'm back in publix
that's crazy rodeo it's amazing that
still exists
i mean that's like
heath
that is bananas
eight seconds i think it's still the
record oh geez hopefully he doesn't
better with the ladies
that is crazy look at that unreal we
gotta i would love to go to a rodeo
those people exist you forget about them
rusty allen
look at that man yeah they just it's
hilarious they're just so committed to
the hat that was like maybe a helmet
would be a good idea right that's true
as a lady does that do anything for you
it's pretty damn manly the not the
horses the mechanical bull i've seen
like some competitions in that that are
impressive
at like a bar yeah you're more impressed
by that than what they're doing you like
bars bad for all the animals i don't
know oh that's a good point no one no
one's getting hurt on that one yeah cows
would rather be like chilling eating
grass not doing that they get these
horses fired up right before they send
them out they go your mother's a [ __ ]
and that's how they get all fired up oh
my god look at that this is just bull
riding i mean this guy you know he
that'd be great if he he could do that
but he just he [ __ ] for like two
seconds
every woman's gotta make fun of them
oh my god like imagine that life oh yeah
like you get older that's no joke that
next morning
yeah like i'm sore from flying i know
right and i was in delta one
yeah you're eating cookies and drinking
beer look at that oh i got kicked by a
hoof
and we're like oh my god they don't
recline all the way
the horses start stomping him put your
mouth on the curb
i'm like what charger doesn't work
that's so true
we're such [ __ ] i had that this
weekend we're such [ __ ] i know
oh dude i was in la i did uh i did
according to doing those shows oh yeah
let's hear about gordon it's kind of fun
it was uh
yeah it was a good time oh she won she
broke one out
it was fun yeah we did uh
it's weird doing late night now though
with like all the coveted tests you have
to take all the forms you have to fill
out you kind of don't want to bring
anyone oh good point yeah so yeah it was
a whole thing and then uh
our buddy ian carmel was a head writer
was there the best guy and the good guy
yeah and then
oh yeah super funny he's on the show now
he does like oh he does like the riffing
with cordon now up top is nate fernald
still there i don't know if he's still
there
yeah he's a funny guy very good writer
yeah good jokes um
according to the thing that's so cool
that not a lot of late night hosts do
he'll come out and he'll be like uh
you guys this is not a normal situation
for a comic you better bring like not
every late night host does that no no
he's a sweet guy but he's like you
better laugh and like they they bring it
oh that's nice did he chat with you in
the in your room yeah yeah yeah nice he
was i don't know if i should say this
but he came into my room he was like
it's good to see some real comedy i went
to the improv the other night it is hack
city and he's like a little cute british
guy so he's like it just hacks
over there you know with the accent and
he was like every joke was what the [ __ ]
and
am i right [ __ ] me holy [ __ ] no punch
lines i was like this guy gets it yeah
but
crowd was hot that's the hottest crowd
in ladies he's like he's like it's all
hacks am i right it's all born
uh no yeah he's a very cool guy he
really is um
yeah man i like i did a couple improv
sets and three actually oh nice improv i
love the improv i like the improv great
good good there ran into like santino
there hey follow ding cook whoa this is
la baby this is [ __ ] this is los
angeles wow what was that like he had a
funny one he closed i didn't really
catch all this stuff but he had a funny
one about
about murder and i was like yeah all
right yeah did he do like an hour or was
it no he did he actually i i've heard
that he goes long and he he was like got
the light
right off okay maybe he was one of those
dudes that like chappelle for a while
was doing like five hour sets exactly
there's no point of this no no five
hours like think about watching a great
three hour movie yeah like watching the
godfather straight through you're like
that was a lot yeah and this every frame
was thought about yes yes and there's
not a demanded reaction good point like
it's very crazy to me it's crazy that
people do that i don't get it it's a
little self-indulgent it's a little
selfish to the staff the staff wants to
go home sure you're doing six hours come
on it's a lot that's a lot
but
to each his anal
you got any uh wrecks
i got a weird one hit me all right
so i was in sacramento as well a couple
weeks ago and some about california i
just want to have a nice craft beer and
i had an anchor steam oh you ever ever
had anchor steam here good man i love
that beer that's in my top three beers
something about the what are your other
favorites i like uh like sierra nevada
i like anchor steam i like uh pilsner
urkel or
i love it there it is that is i love
that beer and i just said i gotta tell
sam about this beer it just hit the spot
so good yeah pilsner i love a pilsner
guy all day how about uh dogfish head i
like dog fishing that's a good beer yeah
dog food coney island uh pilsner is good
too
so yeah there's some great beers not
your go-to though and it's not mine
either we're more of like liquor guys
i'm like an old man now i have a beer
like one beer at the end of the night
i'm just like i sip it i
cherish the beer
20 of them oh my god yeah it's like we
used to it's like jerking off four times
a day versus like becoming older you're
like let me light a candle
yeah let me enjoy myself yeah jizz in my
own stomach
exactly
[Laughter]
you're a stomach jizzer huh oh no your
hand stomach
hairy hand no it's not i'm hairy oh good
point you're gonna turn into a whole
scotch tape situation
you don't want to jerk off my stuff who
does who's who's that [ __ ] late
they're just laying down let me people
do it
he did it yeah yeah yeah but he's a
hairless uh
he's one of hitler's uh aryan little
boys he was half german that guy hitler
would have loved the stefano yeah but
yeah that's like putting gum in a cat
you know it's just hairy bad idea
tangled nah it's not good
all right all right but yeah well what's
your wreck my wreck
all right i mean i got a few dude i got
one all right i've been seeing in six
years book of mormon no come on
it's so good i took my mom i just seen
it too it's still going yeah it's still
going oh i thought it was over no
broadway's back and if you're in new
york you should see a broadway show i
will i'd love to go dude it's [ __ ]
hilarious my mom was the loudest laugh
i mean i don't know why i'm saying a
surprise it's trey parker and matt stone
but like i want to see it forever and i
just never got around to it and yeah
it's it's incredible all right it's so
[ __ ] funny uh it tickets crazy they
were pretty expensive because broadway's
back i feel like it's there's nothing
i'll show you after i don't know oh i
wish you showed me oh yeah you got an
app i got an app yeah no it was uh it's
it's so many good songs there's one song
in particular the the uh the people in
the village thing yes yeah
i mean the premise just to give real
quick the premises they're uh mormons
and they're going on their mission and
everyone wants to go
um
everyone wants like a cool place to go
they're like china oh my god or japan
yeah you know france and he's like i
want and the main guy is mormon so he
thinks orlando is the nicest place he's
obsessed with orlando that's great
but they end up getting uganda
so that's the whole play that they're in
uganda trying to convert these people
with horrible lives to become mormons
got it and these these villagers sing
them this this whole song and you they
think it's like a kuna matata the chant
and it turns out they're screaming [ __ ]
you god oh so they're they're fine we
all have aids yeah they're all yelling
we have aids wow
it's dark [ __ ] it's so lovely
my mom with the lyrics so she could like
really see it and she was like oh my god
thank you so much i was listening to it
on the flight and i was like part of me
is like look i'm not like superstitious
here but i am listening to [ __ ] you god
while on a flight maybe i should switch
the
i used to switch the tune yeah
wow it's it's phenomenal all right i'm
in
yeah you never saw it i never saw it i
well first of all broadway when this was
when this was on broadway originally it
was insane i was broke it was it was
insanely expensive it was the biggest
thing on broadway since the lion king
but now i feel like i can go and it was
bobby moynihan back then everyone's like
no josh can sorry i get them mixed up
chubby brunettes
but yeah
all right who's to call amanda brunette
yeah what do you say just say brown hair
brown haired he's a brunette
yeah i don't know it sounds so like kind
of dainty for a man blonde birch works
both genders yeah yeah but brunette
sounds i i guess it works but it's just
you know no you're right anything with
it at brunette dudette chubbette
yeah that was a section of clothing and
when i was a kid chubbette
that was husky for boys and chubbette
for girls should we do some news stories
we've never done this on the podcast
he doesn't have anything ready
should we i mean we don't have to we
could do other stuff too matt it was
matt's idea to break out some
could do a peeve too i could do a pee if
you want to get you
i got eight peas i got a lot of it i had
nine did i get so many peas oh yeah i
got so many pees my dick doesn't work
i'll tell you
all right
we might be drunk and sponsored by
better help online therapy relationships
take work a lot of us will drop anything
to go help someone we care about we'll
go out of our way to treat other people
well but how often do we give ourselves
the same treatment for me
working out or buying some new sneakers
is an investment in myself this month
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of your most
important relationship the one you have
with yourself we're in therapy we go to
the same guy it's necessary clean out
the garbage your head has all these
horrible thoughts
splicing your childhood traumatic
experiences you're a wreck you're a mess
you need therapy get out the garbage
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for a haircut or even trying therapy
you're your greatest asset so invest
time and effort into yourself like you
do for other people tell them how better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
maybe you got a weird boil on your face
or something you're weird you know you
don't want to see that you're all said
yep it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy we might be drunk is sponsored
by betterhelp and listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash drunk
you gotta do this it's it's therapy very
important take care of yourself it's
gonna change your life here here
we might be drunk is thrilled to welcome
our new sponsor fanimal
i love live events i hate buying tickets
the hidden fees suck and coordinating
with your friends is the nightmare
they're garbage i always end up fronting
a bunch of money and chasing down my
friends to get reimbursed not me
personally because i'm very generous if
they flake i'm stuck with a whole bill
and then i discovered fandible fanable
has tickets to everything there's no
fees the price you see is the price you
pay that's i mean that's pretty big yeah
not only those prices transparent but
they're almost always lower than
anywhere else i look and for any hot
ticket like coachella a laker game or
dave chappelle fanimal is always the
cheapest option nobody gives nobody goes
to live events anymore so why buy
tickets alone fanimal although if you do
come to a show alone there's nothing
wrong with that honestly i love that
someone tweeted me about that the other
day they're like i wanna is it weird my
friend's bail is it weird if i come
alone i said no dude enjoy yourself yeah
and you know what the guy made new
friends at the show they tweeted me
afterwards i sat with these guys and
they were tweeting me too so you end up
having a great time no matter what
um
animals patent group purchase makes it
easy first you set a minimum size for
your group and you choose the number of
tickets you want to pay for yourself
then you invite friends when the minimum
size is met everyone gets charged and
receives their ticket if the minimum
size isn't reached in time nobody gets
charged you don't commit until your
friends you march tell them how mark i
called you march
march march normand tell them how to do
it oh yeah and family has amazing
customer service don't take my word for
it check out their hundreds of five star
reviews the next time you need tickets
go to fanimal.com and sign up with
code drunk
for 20
of credit
20 of credit towards your first purchase
we drink on this show check out fanimel
and experience more support the show and
get twenty dollars off your first
purchase with the code drunk at
fanimal.com f-a-n-i-m-a
dot com get on it
hey we might be drunk is pro brought to
you by geology geology is on a mission
to make men's skin care a breeze take a
30-second diagnostic quiz tell them
about your skin and goals and their team
of dermatologists will design a regimen
just
for you that is shipped directly to your
door it's that simple geology only
includes ingredients that actually make
a difference to your skin no
junk
we love geology look at this skin we got
good skin over here we're doing all
right for a couple of booze bags we're
doing pretty good yeah i mean we're
working toward a red nose yeah right but
until then awesome until then and also
the stubble helps cover up half of it
but yeah our foreheads are solid we're
all right okay their 30-day trial
includes all four of their products
everyday face wash vital morning face
cream repairing night cream nourishing
eye cream
the easy routine equals easy results get
on it fellas head to geology.com
drunk and take those free skincare quiz
and save up to 50 off on your 30 days
trial or just click the link in the show
notes that's geology g e o l o g i e dot
com slash drunk or click on the link in
the show notes and say 50 off on your
30-day trial geology make handsome a
habit that's my don draper voice i like
it doesn't everyone want geology
all right i want to blow you
all right all right here's one
uh yeah i'm with danny jallis very funny
guy we're in sacramento yeah really
smart stuff yeah and also a great
hanging we're in sacramento and we we go
to old sac which is cool it's kind of
fun you got to do it old sack we find a
cool little brunch spot and i go oh
what's the uh
can we get a table and they go uh we
have a two hour and 45 minute wait and
i'm like just say you're full right
don't [ __ ] two hours it's like it's like
literally hitting on a married woman and
she's like i've been married for six and
a half years
just say unavailable uh yeah do you
think i'm gonna wait three [ __ ] hours
for breakfast tacos good point
we don't need the full who's going i'll
i'll wait i'll wait by then it'll be
dinner i know what are you crazy yeah
yeah good good catch
inferior infuriated me yeah okay how
about this one my lady does this one and
i hope i haven't done this peep before
but i'm laying in bed
sleeping and she goes you awake are you
awake well i am now you woke me
i wasn't awake
are you awake i thought that peeve was
gonna be she tries to get food for me
when i'm in first class that's pretty
rude
uh no that's that's that's a definite
peeve i am awake now cause you woke me
up i'm i'm i'm your girlfriend in in my
relationship oh you're you're awake i'm
the one who's like are you uh i'm
because i'm the one who's always up uh
and i'm just annoyed that i'm alone at
that point i'm like i'm like come on
that's her too no it's look yeah you
would be the dude i could see you
falling asleep easily no i mean no i
don't sleep i don't sleep well so that's
why i get so angry because when i'm
asleep and you wake me i'm like it's
ruined i'm done now oh my god it's hard
to get back to sleep yeah
so are you awake just just look at me
i'm snoring you're doing the thing that
wakes the person up exactly gah drives
me crazy it's like when someone like
hits you like that hurt yeah yeah yeah
yeah it'd be like if i was pissing and
someone and there was water there's
urine hitting the bowl and i'm like you
pissing you done pissing no pissing ooh
i don't like people here's a pee even
you just made me people who uh
are pushy when you're peeing if you're
there a long time i'll give you the
aggressive knock sure if you're in there
peeing and they're aggressive i'm like
hey i just got in here right
i'm just getting warmed up pacino
and now you can't pee comfortably
because now you're like oh [ __ ] i'm
rushed it's a bad pee
it's a bad pig it's like chris rock's
joke uh you ever try to rub one out real
quick and somebody's knocking on door
like that's a bad jerk
[Laughter]
it's true you want a clear head with a
urine or a jerk yeah you don't like
pushing out a pee because then at the
end you get that little sting i hate
this thing awful another worse than
pinching a piss too ugh a pinch piss
how about this one
uh i this is a comedian thing that
drives me crazy and i'm gonna hurt some
comedians here but i'm done with it i
hate it you should stop doing it uh-huh
the comma who goes so you know it's some
arbitrary thing like i just turned 33.
oh no claps there like no we don't care
you turn 33. who gives a [ __ ] it's a
worthless age it's not an accomplishment
and you just turned it's not even your
birthday like get out of here with that
yeah when you when you're saying nothing
yeah
just going applause hunting what are you
doing i want a gold medal in the
olympics oh okay okay hey i killed bin
laden all right there we go now we're
talking team six gets applause yes i'm
not applauding for you turning in asia
another one sometimes you get this in
the crowd it's my birthday
hey if i if i'm talking to you and if
i'm doing crow work with you and you say
it's your birthday
i'll [ __ ] buy you a drink whatever
you [ __ ] need but if you just yell
it's my birthday hey guess what we all
have birthdays bad people have birthdays
serial killers have birthdays am i
supposed to celebrate for them too
exactly and this is why you're in a
comedy show not your own [ __ ] party
because you have no friends
they're usually with friends that's true
but don't come to a comedy show on your
birthday i'm sorry hey here's for your
[ __ ] birthday right here yeah you go
for all the birthdays don't don't yell
it out anymore
i got another one for you because it's
raining outside yep
nearly [ __ ] melted in my leprechaun
costume uh-huh but i is that leprechauns
they're gremlins
you can't get them wet you can't get
them away much like jaime
wait wait till i have another one of
these yeah
that's kind of like you're in a western
you see the guy go for the gun and
you're like i got me [ __ ]
uh all right
uh it's raining outside and i'm like you
know walking behind people i don't use
umbrellas i'm not an umbrella guy i'd
rather get wet same if it's [ __ ]
pouring oh hot i'll i'll be crafty with
my moves yes i don't like the umbrellas
i always lose what's the point of an
umbrella it's another thing to carry
then it stops raining you're the jerk
off because wilson must be out of the
house for hours right so i don't like
that
slow walkers in the rain oh
what are you doing what is that it's
raining what is that crazy i'm dodging
umbrellas like uh like uh the matrix out
there by the way those pointy things we
got to stop the points on the umbrellas
why are they so pointed i don't know i
have that clear the dome is nice because
it's individual yeah you don't poke
people in the temple right these people
are out there with a giant it's like
throwing stars it's like a it's like a
weapon yeah i saw a guy spinning one i
was like are you trying to [ __ ] kill
me i know exactly so yeah i'm with you
on that
new york in the rain it gets pretty
tense out here
uh how about this one this is annoying
when people go uh you see that you see
that movie let's just make up a movie
you see that movie uh the brown bear
i don't think i saw it you know the
brown bear with the the bear
yeah i don't think i caught it you saw
it with the uh with matt damon and uh
and bill cosby
i don't think i could that was a good
one
i slept through most of it but
but you know
you you saw i'm like i didn't see it get
to the point of the story i don't care
about your story anyway but now we're
off on me making sure i saw it i didn't
see it
what a crazy thing to be like you saw it
come on i know you saw it it was
everywhere like i didn't see it
yeah no it's annoying the pushy
needs you to just be on board every step
of the way just tell the story tell me
the thing about the movie i'm ready the
brown this is [ __ ] good you see
you come around on these yeah i mean
it's like i mean i'm just drinking a
[ __ ] pint of ice cream i felt like
after i went i came from a pizza contest
where i had to eat a ton of pizza there
you go and now i'm like i mean this is
going to be
my toilet is going to be begging for its
life when i get up oh yeah you're living
the life of a nine-year-old you're
eating pizza all day and then you were
dressed in a costume and having
milkshakes later i'll play with trains
that'd be great
should we do some news stories let's do
it all right uh i got to work
matt why do you have to pull this one
victoria's secret down syndrome model so
sophie giroud is the first model
uh for
for vs victoria's secret
uh with oh yeah with down syndrome is it
okay to be sexually attracted to a
mentally handicapped person well it
better be okay because i've already
finished
but
my point about this is
first of all she's got a mild case
i'd say
but also
i feel bad for the girl who didn't get
it
like who auditioned and was it was it
all down syndrome people was it no i
think it was open casting so the girl it
didn't get it's like what i didn't get
it who got it you don't want to know
that she's very pretty she's pretty
she's she's some real eye candy and i
heard that's what they paid her in but
uh you know
that was it that's all i've done
i'm out i'm pulling out all right what's
the next one what's the next story we're
trying to be very woke with the modeling
yeah you got a vitiligo model
you're going down all the way what are
you doing i saw that
yeah the alopecia model too oh they got
an alopecia yeah
you should text her i heard she's uh
down to [ __ ]
uh khabib versus max holloway so mma
stars fight in a virtual boxing match
held in facebook's metaverse khabib has
been retired from the mma since uh
making the promise to his mother when
his father died unexpectedly this is his
first fight since march 2021 khabib won
the exchange mostly uh
put for yeah it's this is so weird
that's weird i i worry about this [ __ ]
because we're already lazy everything's
already delivered to our house uber eats
and now we're going a step further with
like porn is now
meta and we're gonna start going into a
metal comedy show we're going to be out
of work well i think yeah i mean this is
like this is going to show what big
[ __ ] we become too yes
oh you want to take it outside
uh uh
and by that i mean to our computers
yeah i'll [ __ ] i hope i kick you i
don't know who my demo character is yeah
i think it's good exactly you talk about
riding horses now it's like yeah i ride
horses and then put the goggles on and
they ride a horse it's not the same
you need the touch the feel the risk
yeah i i wouldn't i don't think comedy
is in danger i mean we saw that with the
pandemic people wanna i hope you're
right i don't think so i mean
cut to a year later we're like i hope
you saved mark yeah because
people don't want to leave their home
wait what are we all gonna be buying
green screens real soon what else a
weird daniel daniel radcliffe of harry
potter will be playing weirdo
in a new uh biopic
that's uh oh wow opening act emo
phillips that's cool hey i love you moe
love it yeah that's holy [ __ ] it's so
weird because he's like a serious actor
and it's just not who you would think
would
it's like if my friend does his makeup
so oh yeah
wow it's like it's like if daniel day
lewis was playing baba bowie
but it's just it's like a weird yeah
thing look at that he looks like a cross
between uh 80s
he's kind of got a little bit of
uh
trying to think who do what does that
look like
he looks like a guy who you pay to fix
your uh tv but he ends up jerking off in
the bathroom
doesn't he
it's a weird look over there with the uh
with the weird al
great head of here
i guess he's gotta get a little screech
in him yeah and it's if screech [ __ ]
around jeremy maybe
but good for radcliff because he's going
if that happened it wouldn't have been
consensual i'll tell you that
he needs a style change though he's so
in-depth to harry potter and he's so
like known as right yeah he's gotta cut
loose yeah looks a little bit i mean
dude i loved weird al like eat it
eat it
was the best food album spam killer
bangers dude i met him he's the sweetest
guy yeah baloney i'm bad
all the 80 stuff i'm fat i'm fat yeah
really really he owes a lot of credit i
mean dude beat it as the cashier song oh
yeah eat it
eat it oh amish paradise paradise is
brilliant yeah pretty flush did we skip
some oh wait lois grossing movie
z i've never heard of this
z-y-z-z-y-x rose is that a new gender
thirty dollars starring catherine heigl
and tom seismore that's not possible
holy [ __ ] yeah you would think that the
producers would just buy a few tickets
to kill what the hell yeah
people hate that heigl they don't like
her yeah sizemore i love she still looks
good though she looks great
whoa damn how did okay i'm thinking
about renting this already yeah wait now
maybe not anymore it does look a little
shoddy
where'd they shoot the song who named
this movie flip phone
yeah the name is what killed it sweet
how do you say it like something i think
elon musk named the movie
after his daughter
yeah this looks
this is like the blair witch project i
mean it's like a shot horribly it's very
grainy it's very camcordery
you could have made way more money if it
was just her in the bikini for a while
that's true
right now
even size more in a bikini might have
pulled
because you'd be like wait what yeah
exactly i'll click on that sizemore had
a run he had a run saving private ryan
uh he went to rehab though i think yeah
i heard
me put him back
he'd be a good guest i would love to
have him on
oh yeah yeah this looks like [ __ ] it
does look bad
leah grillo
top size more oh he got put behind
grillo
yeah i think people just don't like her
i guess
worse
well in hathaway's working yeah i would
say absolutely and hathaway
isn't she an oscar winner i mean she is
she's [ __ ] working
i think people just don't like anne
hathaway's like essence or something
like i think it's like more like where
it's like her they think they just
actually don't like yeah hathaway's got
a little let me speak to your manager
look
and also it's like she's very like she's
such i don't think people like actors
who are that much actors yeah right i
think they want you to like she seems
like she the way like pete buddha judge
seems like he was made in a lab for
politics that's what she
seems like she did she was pretty i
can't get that one out because of your
[ __ ] ice cream shamrock shake
baby what uh what else do we have did we
miss anything else i feel like you went
you went by some i think matt weird out
oh yeah look at that all right oh love
is blind season two of i've never seen
the show season two of netflix
reality series about finding love
without seeing the other person
premiered last week can love really be
blind are they blind i'm sorry
oh they don't they're in like different
rooms they can only hear each other oh
there's a gun there's not a great payoff
if they're actually blind mark yeah
they're just like i don't know what you
look like and at the end i still don't
know what you look like
there's a guy on this season that scene
is mental though oh really somebody said
on tick tock that it seems like
he's what big
would have happened in real life like he
made a wish and he's actually eight
years old because he doesn't really oh
interesting
i gotta say his name pete lee oh this
guy the one that um
we love people
like him
oh yeah i could see it oh yeah yeah
he's got a little vibe there
i will say if you're hearing a lady and
not seeing her that's kind of the worst
of everything
oh wow they went up together
i
took a stretch i took a leap no no no
that was funny i was i was looking at
the picture that was good what should we
do another story what else olympics i
forgot the olympus were on i mean i just
don't care no one cares it's a doping
thing and i'm like i don't i don't care
i will say i can watch curling for three
days really i just something it's like
you just like her hair
[Laughter]
it's like
um catharina i don't know i just laid
but it's relaxing yeah
eileen goo and zu yi both born in like
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
it's a girl
born in the united states have decided
to compete in the olympics on the
chinese team this has caused some anger
from groups upset them turning on that
is a weird move there
i don't know
there's so
you would think you just want to play
for warrior but this is like also kind
of like part of this new progressive
thing where like will i identify as this
right
but it's like but you were born here
it's weird right it's a little weird but
i guess obviously they're asian descent
of course yeah yeah i mean that'd be
weird if they were like you know german
yeah i just want to play on china really
bad right did you hear about the skier
with the frozen penis what
pull it up there's a scheme from an
olympics with a frozen penis did it
freeze in the in the race i didn't read
the story but the headline got me they
found it inside his body i've heard of a
friend and tom is the name wow wait a
minute at least he's hard
[Laughter]
damn did it freeze out there
oh matt agreed to that pretty quick remy
lindholm winter olympian suffers
unbearably painful frozen penis after
cross-country skiing race so it was the
race was that long and it froze his [ __ ]
i like that it says like unbearably it's
like yeah i think frozen you had me at
frozen penis it doesn't sound good good
point my feet fall asleep i'm like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh yeah
damn wow look at his face he's got ice
on it or something it's funny to be
going down the hill being like my dick
man frozen [ __ ] i've never heard of this
yeah
how about that frostbitten yeah frozen
[ __ ] sounds like a thai dessert
[Laughter]
all right all right well fun news story
all right we got a new little segment
here folks
[Music]
any uh
any peeves
how far in are we i don't want to go to
a bit too early
what are we at there peters
oh
[ __ ]
i flew by i mean i got a few ideas
frozen dick who knew
frozen dick hey that was a good new
segment yeah i like that good segment
really seems to good
all right all right what do you any uh
any bits we should try i got a bid i got
a couple ideas
all right help me out with this one you
too
so it's you know where i hate how
divided the country is i hate how
splintered everything is isn't it weird
that we have two news stations that tell
you the same story but with a different
take like just tell me the news the news
should just be facts black and white
tell it to me why do i have your opinion
your spin thank god they don't do this
with the weather
wouldn't that be horrible if they had
two different weathers you know like
let's check that we're going to the
beach tomorrow let's check the liberal
weather hey it's going to rain all day
because you [ __ ] won't take climate
change seriously and somehow this is joe
rogan's fault what the [ __ ]
all right [ __ ] this let me check the uh
the alt-right weather or the right-wing
weather and they're like hey grab your
boots cause it's 100 chance of storming
the
all right i don't know if that's
anything they'll be hailing and hiling
oh this is good you like that i don't
know have you tried stretch have you
tried it i've tried it but it's it's a
lot it's a mouthful so i haven't really
said it smoothly hailing and highland
that kills yeah hailing and island but
uh i don't know is storming the the
capital is that they're not acting
it does okay
i don't think everybody's getting it
right a lot of people don't watch the
news anymore they're too depressed who
doesn't know about the capital that's
like i know about that so that's
storming i figured i had a connection
with the storm weather of course all
right so it totally works all right i'll
keep it then because i was nervous about
it i like that i had a bit it's not i
don't think it's the same but it was
like uh about how uh
i was working on like how when you're
arguing with your girlfriend it's like
you just can't find middle ground like
like it's almost like if a person
like she only watched fox news and i
only watched cnn and then of course
of course we can't agree on a reality
this is your show and this is mine right
it's i think it's different that's
totally different but that that's a good
angle yeah yeah it's so true because two
people watch the same story on the news
but different channels and they have a
different completely different take on
it and then our therapist that we buy we
both learn therapists and like like my
therapist thinks that uh cnn's pretty
good she's like well my therapist only
watches fox right right you know it's
like yeah you find people you start
align yourself with people who just
agree with you exactly you watch uh cnn
they're like this kyle rittenhouse guy's
crazy comes in with a machine gun and
you watch fox news like this hero yeah
he's you know
carlson's holding him like a baby
little baby kyle so it's just weird like
you could also do this with thank god
they don't do it with sports teams you
know like oh we're we're for the bengals
so we thought they won i love you call
them the bangles
what do you call the bengals
whoops sorry
well i also love shout out to the rims
super bowl mark's favorite sports team
is the cars
[Laughter]
all right what do you got bit wise i got
a couple ideas i can't crack so i have
one i don't know if i run this by i knew
a kid who commit murder growing up did i
tell you this okay it was a big news
story he murdered a woman i know him
well but i knew him well enough that it
was shocking on purpose
yeah oh wow strangled her it was hard
yeah it was a terrible terrible story
and
i was uh talking to a friend about him
and my friend because we both we
actually weirdly met through him because
he just like had a thing at a bar and we
met and i was like he's one of my this
other guy's one of my best friends now
wow and it turns out i know other people
that know him
uh but the the murder guy i played hoops
them a few times we weren't close but
like it's shocking yeah you said the
angle of course i'm on the phone my
friend
and he's like man you know what i know
when i knew when that guy was a piece of
[ __ ] he told me to come all the way up
town to see a movie and then he bails at
me five minutes before with the three
word text and i was like what i got news
for you uh you got off easy
i don't know if you heard what happened
but he's not he's not doing in time in
prison for being a bad movie buddy
[Laughter]
and then there's this angle of like this
other guy was like well you got to visit
him in prison i was like no i wasn't
even that close to them he's like you
got i mean you can't be a fair-weather
friend i was like if the weather's
murdering people
i think it's okay to say [ __ ] the
weather right yeah exactly
i don't know how to do this part but
like if there's a hurricane
you evacuate yes you don't you don't say
if you stay put you're a [ __ ] idiot
that's good yeah you don't go into the
storm yeah yeah that's funny i don't go
into the storm thinking like maybe it's
changed i don't know it's been a little
while yeah
yeah it'd be nice if there was a weather
report on how your friend's doing like
is he still a murderer ooh that's good
weather on a girlfriend weather app yes
yes i think that's an old is that a bit
no i thought you had that bit about
girlfriend weather would be nice if you
could check it
not me
i tried a bit i never did anything with
it like how you i wish like their
stories were like calling an uber and
you could be like all right eight
minutes left and then you're like then
then you look down you're like 16
minutes now how did that get longer you
know i never did anything with that [ __ ]
that's good really yeah i like that a
lot
all right then you could write the story
at the end
that's funny yes
um something the murder thing is so
crazy that's insane that happened insane
you knew it you know murder horrible
yeah
at least he was caught yeah wouldn't
that be weird if you knew he was a
murderer and he was still out there he's
like do you want to hang out i'm like
i'm not come i'm not seeing a movie with
you
yeah maybe your friend's lucky he bailed
on the movie he might have been next
i'm like how angry did you get with him
yeah yeah
uh
yeah you're like i was gonna go visit
him but i choked
all right
i don't know that's a heavy premise too
because
you're dealing with a death
murder yeah
[ __ ]
man but that's great the uh the movie
thing maybe you know like
yeah i like what you have about the uh
the
cable news like how
it was like thank god the weather
it should just be facts tell me what's
what maybe there's like a really uh
really right wing there's like a news
max version of it and it's like it's
like uh
it's like you know
uh you're jewish you're burning in hell
and you're like jesus right
right oh yeah
wear sunscreen because you're going to
hell yeah yeah that's funny
is there anything about how like when
you were a kid you know i'd watch the
news to see if i could go skateboarding
the next day so i'd watch the weather
and then it would say it's going to rain
all day and then you'd wake up in the
morning it was sunny and i'd be like mom
it's going to rain they're like you
can't trust the weather those guys don't
know that's interesting so yeah now that
feels like the news you know they're
like this guy's a racist and you're like
well let me read the story
yeah you used to hear this guy's eraser
you're like oh my god yeah well don't
you wish the news
had the same pull as the weather where
the weather's like it could change it
could change you know fouchy's like why
can't i get that exactly maybe there's
something maybe there's something about
that i don't know yeah
i always said fauci was like the coveted
groundhog oh gosh anytime he pops up six
more weeks we're all getting sick of
them i think so
i think there's going to be a hell of a
documentary about this in ten years this
whole code hopefully it's ten years i
think it's two or three might be two or
three even better yeah a lot of shit's
gonna come out oh although aren't we all
sick of this [ __ ] oh yeah i'm going to
wuhan next year i got to get yeah they
got a good funny bone there
i'm playing
funny bun yeah my features are bad
and uh
it's a wet market over there
all right you got any bits
uh i had something that
wait seriously i mean
if you want oh okay sure i mean it's
real like i mean i so i lost my
virginity one month after 9 11. oh
[Laughter]
no yes it was just uh it was a
vulnerable time he played hacky sack he
had a lazy eye so
clearly i just kind of picked whomever
because i just didn't want to die a
virgin right yeah there was like that
whole thing of like never forget for 9
11 but like with that it was like i
didn't want to remember so like never
remember
uh
all right yeah there's something there
there's something there
the whole forgetting thing let me block
it out yes
i'll block it out
right he was a first responder maybe
he called somebody he showed up first
i like remember losing virginity was uh
that was a big deal maybe maybe like
afterwards he evacuated the building oh
that's good there were no jews in the
building
yeah
um all right there's a lot of rubble
when he left there was rubble and fire
he ruined it like everyone had the like
suffered from like the aftermath oh yeah
yeah i had the long-term effects right
i'm sick now yeah i deserve like
compensation or something
oh yeah compensation
i like it you're traumatized from the
experience
you got in a cab went up town
were you guys here for that yeah
i was in school whoa
midtown yeah wow yeah i remember i had a
teacher give us a pop quiz the day of
and we knew that we were under attack it
was crazy i remember i remember being
like are you [ __ ] kidding me wow yeah
we were furious
damn yeah my dad picked me up we all
lined up to donate blood and but that's
new york is like the lines were too long
like everyone was like we'll donate
blood you know yeah
it was more like it was like it's not
like you need that much blood for that
[ __ ] it was more like this is we're
[ __ ] here yes we're helping yeah
community
i remember the greg gerald remember the
greg gerald a bit
about like he knew the terrorists didn't
win when he saw his first bachelorette
party after 9 11.
just a bunch of a bunch of women like i
don't care what those [ __ ] mexicans
did oh that's great i do remember that
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah a lot of uh like brown guys that
are like indian and stuff like that they
were just [ __ ] with
hard after even in new orleans
that got ugly it was ugly it was awful a
lot of a lot of black comes like they're
the new n words
[Laughter]
all right well well any dates to put
when does this oh my god right when you
want to pull up our shed dude oh yeah
oh how's the beacon cooking i think
we're done oh my god that's incredible i
think there's like there's like
10 to 15 singles left okay it's just
singles but i think i mean is that what
they plugged on i mean by the time this
comes out it'll be sold out is that what
they plugged on
yeah but that's a good plug yeah it's a
good plug he was cool about it he was
like oh it's the best venue you know
yeah
that's what they they say the beacon in
the is like the wilbur almost for new
york yeah all right i'm in tampa florida
i'm in louisville kentucky i'm in uh
uh dania beach florida whatever that is
i'll be there too soon all night
paramount theater in austin for uh moon
tower phoenix arizona
addison improv in texas i love that club
i go every year classic classic great
club outside of dallas all kinds of fun
dates out to lunch on youtube special uh
stand-ups on netflix give it a whirl
check out the patreon we got a
columbus uh funny bone salt lake city
wise guys comedy club great club brea
improv in california
beacon theater i assume will be sold out
unless we other one i don't think we
will
nashville tennessee uh zany's albany
funny bone toronto we added another show
there for the bluma appel theater there
and uh we got uh east providence rhode
island the comedy connection we got all
kinds of [ __ ] coming up uh yeah can't
wait to see you guys on the road tampa
cleveland all that [ __ ] and uh
probably chicago soon too so keep an eye
out hey yeah chicago raleigh fun stuff
in the mix what do we got on merch uh
peter is anything
oh it's cooking oh yeah look at that we
might be drunk pod.com or we might be
drunk yeah we might be drunkpod.com look
at us we're adorable in those tuxes man
we have a website i had no idea
hey i didn't know this either look at
all that merch koozies t-shirts coasters
bottle openers oh whiskey's coming soon
oh that's right
i just did hey babe and i plugged the
the hell out of the whiskey oh yeah dude
so it's coming out in a while but yeah
we're gonna we're gonna be selling some
hot hot rye folks so buckle up
all right thank you
patreon.com we might be drunk pod make
sure to review us follow the the we
might be drunk instagram follow us
see us on the road
so much uh so much good stuff cooking
good stuff cooking you might have a
special who knows what's going on jamie
what are you what are you plugging
uh i have shows in new york definitely
the
march 6th and 13th i always post on my
uh instagram jamie samantha lynn oh
there you go called the jaime way
j-a-i-m-a hell yeah
got it got it and uh website or anything
no not yet
insta
what's that insta did you do instead
yeah jamie samantha oh sorry i've been
drinking
all right we love you guys uh keep uh
keep telling friends about the pod happy
saint patties
stay safe luck of the irish top of the
morning
patty old blue eyed devil well what are
the i don't know any of the the irish
stuff we did we didn't irish cheer give
it give us put up an irish toast at the
end there well we'll say it here
just play us out with the dropkick
murphys or something
boondock saints is overrated awful awful
man i posted that on an instagram story
and i got so much hate
like [ __ ] you that movie rules exactly
all right to all the days here and after
may there be filled with fond memories
happiness and laughter may the best day
of your past be the worst day of your
future
always remember to forget the things
that made you sad but never forget to
remember the things that made you glad
boy these guys aren't known for their
rap
always spit on your dick before you get
hard yeah that's a weird one right there
holy [ __ ] if you're gonna have sex with
victoria's secret model
go for the down syndrome one last
maybe in heaven with a half full out
with a full half hour before the devil
knows you're dead dance as if no one
were watching singing if no one were
listening and live every day as if we're
your last i mean all right we're gonna
cliche here frozen dick why are people
always dancing like no one's watching at
some point people are going to watch yes
you might want to work on those moves i
agree i'll tell you you're right yeah
may we all be alive at the same time
next year jesus christ this guy's
getting a
dui
the last one's just i hate you mom
you're like jesus
that's crazy all right to all the small
dicks out there and uh the patio potato
that's a great uh brian brian kylie joke
you know
i am really irish my blood my blood
what do you call it blood type blood
type is uh oh apostrophe
all right joke that's good uh he's good
he's got some great some uh classics
he's like my name is very irish not as
irish with my friend potato mcsmall
penis
it's classic all right now i'm just
doing his act all right all right you're
all right
thank you guys top of the board
take it easy
[Music]
i've had a little too much
and i get down in the same way
up on the roof like a cob coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same way
we might
be
true
[Music]